we're learning about the dramatic rescue  of an eight-year-old girl in Texas after  a harrowing kidnapping right on the  street here the mother's anguish cries  for help that's in Fort Worth back in  May she fell to the ground after a car  driven by the suspect sped off with the  little girl a tip led police to a hotel  the very next day and newly released  video shows heavily armed officers using  a battery ram battering ram rather to  force their way through a hotel door  they pulled out 51 year-old Michael Webb  inside the officers found the girl  hidden in a laundry basket Webb admitted  he kidnapped the girl just the day  before  he was sentenced to life in prison last  week Wow incredible in just another  advertisement if I had a house I would  certainly have a ring doorbell because a  ring doorbell show that our mo would  happen it's amazing terrified